This is not meant to be sensational.
There's no need for us to
sensationalize any data.
But the truth of the matter is for
the last two to three years now,
guns have been the leading
cause of death among kids.
Physicians are treaters of the sick
and preservers of the healthy.
So, there really is nothing else
that a group of physicians
would rally behind
other than saving lives.
This epidemic is uniquely American.
Gun violence is a public health
issue and a health-care issue.
This is not Democratic or Republican.
This is just protecting humans.
Sometimes you have to lose.
Sometimes you have
to push a boulder up
a hill and it has to crash
back down on you.
But you won't succeed
without ever trying.
America supports all these bills.
And it needs to be the time now
where the politicians realize
that if government doesn't back us,
that they're going to be voted out.
They won’t be politicians anymore.
Exactly.
We have seen that when we take public
health approaches, that we save lives.
Motor vehicle accidents are no longer
the number one cause
of death of children
because of safer cars and car seats.
We can use that same
public health approach
to discuss guns and
gun safety legislation
and create meaningful change.
How can we as medical experts,
help you guys?
So what do you need?
Do you need more doctors
from your state that we can help
provide you to provide evidence?
Do you need us to come
to hearings for you?
We are here to collaborate with
your office to whip these votes
because we are sick of letting
children die every day.
A typical day is going
from meeting to meeting.
No breaks.
Lobbying all day and presenting
our statistics and data and research.
I usually try to open and say,
my name is Dr. Emily Lieberman.
I'm a pediatrician, a wife, a mother.
I am now also a mass shooting survivor.
And I have the unfortunate but unique
perspective of now being a survivor
of gun violence and also a pediatrician
who treats people in the community
who have suffered from gun violence.
And I think that sets us apart
from a lot of the other meetings.
We live in Highland Park,
which prior to July 4th of last year,
I think anyone would say
was probably one of the safest
appearing communities in the country.
We're kind of Pleasantville
for lack of a better word.
On our nation's most patriotic day,
July 4th, our family woke up,
put on 4th of July attire
and met with cousins and my parents.
Our children were in the streets.
There was laughter.
We’re waving to politicians.
And then all of a sudden there is
a horrible popping sound overhead.
And it becomes clear very
quickly that this is a gun.
Seven people were killed and
more than 48 others were injured
after a gunman opened fire at a 4th
of July parade in Highland Park, Illinois.
According to the Gun Violence Archive,
it was one of 647 mass shootings
that took place in 2022.
Unfortunately, we've learned
that we can't keep our children safe
when most of these weapons
are on the streets.
But what we can do is help
prevent these shootings
from continuing to occur,
which is what we are here to do now
for the rest of our life.
This is a pediatric surgery OR.
And so typically when a patient rolls
in, they're going to be lying down here.
This is where the anesthesiologist is.
And then once the patient is asleep,
the whole team kind of functions
very much as a well-oiled machine.
We've here on the front lines have
seen, have felt that 350% increase
in the number of kids with gun
injuries last year, here in New York.
The teams are getting
increasingly fatigued.
The trauma from having to deal with
not only children who have gun injuries,
but their families.
And constantly telling families
that they've either lost a loved one
to a preventable disease or that their kid
is now disabled for life or brain dead.
In little children, all the
organs are closer together.
And as a result, every bullet can
injure that many more organs.
And is that much more devastating than,
let's say, a bullet injury in a adult.
We have a universal screening program
here in our emergency departments
where we actually screen
all patients for firearm injury risk.
And if you screen positive for that,
there are resources we can give you
that help break that cycle of violence
before the gunshot even happens.
Good morning.
AAP guidelines suggest that the best
advice is to not have a gun in the home.
But for those gun owners
that actually do have guns,
research shows that only 50%
of them are safely storing it.
So something that we give out to
our patients are these cable locks.
This will go through the
unloaded, empty firearm.
It goes in one spot there.
You'll lock it.
The key comes out.
And you have a safe firearm.
When we talk about gun violence,
we are referring to firearm-related
suicides, unintentional injuries,
otherwise known as accidental injuries.
We're talking about
intentional firearm injuries,
which could be firearm violence/assault
or in a small sliver of cases,
things like public mass shootings.
And it's really important that we
start having this discussion in a very
nuanced, granular way
because that is the only way
that we're going to have a productive
conversation around potential solutions.
You can imagine that the
solutions to firearm suicide
are far different than the solutions
needed to stop mass shootings,
which are far different than the solutions
that are needed for firearm violence.
We cannot lump it all together.
I've lived in the same
house my whole life and
I don't see myself
moving anytime soon.
We're here to stay. City kid.
Growing up in this neighborhood,
gun violence, it’s always been prevalent.
Always something I've seen around me.
It just never dawned on me
that it could affect me in a way
that would change my life.
The night of the shooting,
we had just went on a family outing.
Came back home. Everyone was in bed.
I decided to go back
outside for a charger
and I was sitting in the
passenger seat of the car.
And all of a sudden someone
runs up to the driver's side.
They said something, waved some
hand symbols, and that was it.
They just started unloading.
When we got to the hospital,
the only injury was
gunshot wound to the back.
I had a nicked vertebrae,
a severed spinal cord,
and both my lungs were ruptured,
internal bleeding, the whole nine yards.
I still have the bullet in my chest today.
I was in the hospital for about six weeks.
I was on my mother's insurance.
It was an HMO.
So we got lucky.
We didn't have to pay for the visit.
But the visit itself was
north of 00,000.
When I left the hospital,
I thought the hardest
part of the journey was done,
but that was not true.
When I got home, I realized
I got steps in the front and the back,
and now I can't use my legs.
How am I going to get up there?
While insurance providers tend to cover
the majority of medical bills immediately
following a shooting, survivors
say costs continue to rack up over time.
Physical therapy or home renovations
may not be covered by insurance
and finding programs to help cover
the costs can be a challenge.
As a result, many patients have
turned to crowdsourcing to fundraise
for ongoing care needs.
There's a lot of things that have
had to come out-of-pocket
because there are just niche enough
for the insurance not to cover them.
But important enough that you
actually need them with a disability.
So, I would say roughly maybe
$20,000 to $30,000 total,
as of now, has been paid out of pocket.
Treating gunshot wounds and
patients is extremely expensive.
We know that treating a patient
with gun injuries, for example,
is three times more expensive than
treating any other type of trauma.
This really speaks
to the complexities of the wounds,
the complications that result from it,
and the long, ongoing disabilities
that really require a lot of
intense medical management.
So here we're seeing that gun
violence costs the United States
over $550 billion per year,
which is an extraordinary amount.
Our politicians who enabled
this assault weapons ban in 1994
truly were trailblazers at the time.
And sadly, the clause was written
that it would sundown in ten years.
So from my perspective,
we're asking Washington, DC
to reinitiate a law that was a law.
We're not rewriting the
history books here.
We are asking them to
continue the history books.
The rates of gun violence
are only going up.
As we delved deeper and saw
how much of a problem this is,
these underserved communities,
the health disparities.
Specifically, Brown and Black communities having
horrific day-to-day gun violence.
And losing many more Brown and
Black people to gun violence.
We realized that we have to really
broaden, as physicians,
some of our lobbying.
We do know that gun-safety policies,
such as assault weapon bans,
background checks, waiting
periods, licensing requirements
that most gun owners actually
do support, will save lives.
And then we know that other policies,
for example, that address the root
causes of structural racism, inequity
will improve firearm violence
in inner-city communities.
So my question really always is:
how can we have that
conversation in a way
that legitimizes both
sides and their concerns
that can really lead to
productive solutions rather than
just this, them-versus-us discussion.
I’m going probably, probably,
I’m probably going to win.
Uno!
If this is the public health crisis
that we believe it is, then
gun violence prevention is going to
be a priority in the next election.
And these lawmakers need to be held
accountable for their decisions.
Childhood trauma and violence
perpetuates childhood
trauma and violence.
And so in this country,
as we continue to have
more and more gun violence
and children who are
witnessing these horrific events,
how it's affecting their family.
They're actually more likely
to become violent themselves.
We're trying to change the narrative
in our house to: something terrible
happened and our parents did
everything possible to try to protect us.
And teach them that despite
adversity that might happen,
we will always try to rise above it
and find solutions to problems.
But our question is
back to the lawmakers.
Have they done everything
in their power to save lives?